Okay, so if the Handmaid's Tale were real,
my 41 year old ass that I already had 4 kids
would probably be an Aunt Lydia.
And something about.
Whenever I wear one of these like solid color jumpsuit things,
I can't help but think of that.
And I need you younger little girls,
women, ladies.
Mad respect.
I need you younger women to know that if I ever was an Aunt Lydia,
I'm gonna be the one that you can count on you.
I'm gonna be watching for you little sneaky bitches.
And I'm gonna be providing the way out.
And the dumb bitches that are like super bought into the handmade shit,
they're gonna be under my fucking eye.
And I'm gonna be watching them little bitches
and opening up their fucking eyes.
And not in the nasty way,
in the real way.
I'm gonna be like, wake the fuck up!
You know, like low key like
this Aunt Lydia is not gonna fucking pretend
I'm not young enough to be a Mrs. Waterford.
I will never be, uh,
fucking whatever her name is offered.
I won't ever be one of those, um.
Those days are behind me.
I would totally be an Aunt Lydia
if they didn't send me to the fucking fucked up place,
which is probably where I would go.
But I could smooth my way into Aunt Lydia.
And this Aunt Lydia's got you fucking covered.